hello everybody this is Gary Vaynerchuk
and this is my 120 and first I want to
tell you what my 120 is there's been
some confusion a lot of people think
it's a minute and 20 seconds but it's a
hundred and twenty seconds which is two
minutes today I'm doing my 120 I'm just
lounging I'm kind of tired I don't know
if anybody else is tired I've been
traveling a lot just got back from
Virginia speaking of the new new
internet had a crazy weekend got a new
MacBook had bring it back cuz of the
clicky thing down here a clicky thing
was not working got stuck and no origami
star fixes yet or anything like that so
that that that was a headache and then
went to the Knicks game last night and I
don't know if anybody else is tired out
there I'm just curious if anybody else
is really tired of tape five episodes
today of WL TV and then went to a
meeting and I'm on my way to Vegas on
Wednesday I hope I see some people a
BlogWorld if you're there hit me up on
Twitter Gary Vee on Twitter I'd love to
meet up and then Thursday and Friday I
am in LA and then I'll be home and next
week is my birthday I'm gonna turn 32
which is devastating for lack of a
better word and I don't know just really
happy though all in all dead tired but
extremely happy because as long as my
parents and my sister and brother and
wife and anybody I care about is healthy
are great and happy and healthy then
life is good that's what life is all
about the people you care about and have
so many great friends and close people
that I care about and I just really want
to continue to video blog every day I
can love doing WL TV huge thank you to
everybody who watches and I hope you
watch garyvaynerchuk.com pass it on
we're having a lot of fun with it and
I'm tired and I'm done I'll see you soon
on my 120